>> FERNANDEZ: My name is Peter Fernandez.
I'm the head of AdMob for Latin America. We
are a mobile advertising network that was
acquired by Google within the past year. And
I'm here to talk a little bit about how you
can make money with mobile applications using
mobile advertising. I'm going to talk about
things like different business models you
can use including advertising and other models
as well, how you can build an audience and
of course, what everyone always wants to know
which is how much money can you actually expect
to make. So before I get started, I actually
just wanted to ask just to understand who's
in the audience, how many people here are
actually--currently have a mobile app or planning
on developing one? Show of hands. Oh, a good
of amount. Great. Awesome. We love you, guys.
So--then I'll just jump right into it. Starting
at the very highest level as I'm sure you've
all heard, the Mobile Internet is obviously
kind of a big deal. Gartner is projecting
that over one billion mobile devices will
be accessing the mobile--the Internet by 2013.
I've seen plenty of other projections saying
that mobile devices are going to be bigger
than regular PC Internet for accessing the
Internet within the next five or so years.
And then Nielsen is projecting that smartphones
are going to overtake what we call feature
phones which are your more basic WAP phones
by Q4 of 2011. That's the end of next year.
So things are changing very rapidly and that's
evidenced by certain things like, for example,
the amount of money that is actually being
transacted through mobile nowadays. You may
have heard that last year eBay did $600 million
worth of sales through mobile applications.
So these are becoming a very viable model
of commerce. And of course, one--this one
survey recording here at the bottom found
that 80% of brands and advertisers are planning
on boosting their mobile budgets in the coming
years. So it's something that people who advertise,
people who want to reach users are thinking
about investing in. And that means that if
you can build an audience of mobile users,
you have a market, you have something you
can sell to advertisers and that's a great
way to build the business. Specifically in
Brazil, so that you guys can understand sort
of the local context, Mobile Internet is exploding.
This is a picture of our network and these
are ad requests. So you can think of these
as page views. Every time--every time there's
a page view, there is also an ad request for
an ad to be shown. That's what's being measured
here. As you can see over the past year, the
network has grown about 800%. I mean it's
staggering. We now have about 220 million
page views per month. If you compare that
to large Internet portals, I mean, that's
what a large Internet portal has. So mobile
is already getting to the scale of PC on certain
measures. In other words, there's a massive
audience. And the reason we have Android and
iPhone pulled out separately from WAP devices
is because the behavior on those devices is
fundamentally different. Those right now are
the primary devices that have full-featured
Internet browsers. And so what you see is
the number of page views per device per day
is just staggeringly higher than on WAP devices.
On WAP devices, you'll get someone using the
mobile Internet. They'll do maybe 10 to 15
page views. On Android, it will be like 60
to 100. So it's just completely--sorry--Android
and iPhone, a completely different ballgame.
And of course, other manufacturers are building
other phones which are beginning to show behavior
like that as well. But right now, the predominant
models that are--that show that behavior are
Android and iPhone. Again in Brazil, in terms
of unique users, just so you can get a sense
of how many people in Brazil are actually
currently using these devices, you can see
also growing extremely fast. Only four months
ago in June 2010, there were about 450,000
users total of Android plus iPhone plus iPod
Touch plus iPad. Just in September, it's basically
almost doubled to 810,000. And very interestingly,
you can see the blue bar just got bigger than
the red bar this past month. There are actually
now more Androids--Android devices in Brazil
than iPhones, which is a pretty interesting
thing to look at. One other thing to note
is that iPad is actually--although it still
looks very small, it's actually growing very,
very, very quickly. So it's an interesting
platform to pay attention to. So what we do
is we allow you if you are able to build an
audience among users of these devices to serve
advertisements to those users. So these are,
you know, an Android app and an iPhone app
in the yellow circles. Those are some of the
ads that you might get if you signed up as
AdMob publisher. Basically, what you do is
you designate certain portions of your app
at places where you would like to show users
ads. And then we go around and talk to advertisers
and sell that inventory to them and do all--basically,
we do all the ad sales for you. So you basically
just turn us on and start making money. As
far as apps go, we have SDKs for iPhone, iPad,
Android and also Palm webOS. And we have a
variety of ad units which I'll show you some
pictures of soon. And of course, we have very
good tracking and analytics tools to keep
track of how well you're doing. Advertising
is just one piece of a business model if you're
an app developer. There is a lot of different
ways you can go. So one thing we see a lot
of is app developers having a free version
and a paid version. And what they'll do is
they'll try to get a big audience with their
free version and then ask people to upgrade
to get extra features to a paid version. So,
in other words, you know, you love this game
that I've developed, you really want levels
five through ten, upgrade to, you know, the
paid version and that's a good model. For
once, you've build trust with your users once
the user values your app. So that's one way
that you can create revenues is by having
that paid version for people to upgrade to.
The second one is in app purchases which is
very similar. This would be something like
if it was a game, for example, offering extra
weapons or extra avatars, that sort of thing;
a dollar for a level pack, that kind of thing;
also a revenue stream. You could just have
a free app and serve advertising in it and
that's obviously something that we see a lot
in our network. And then you can do pretty
much any combination of those three things.
The point that I wanted to make with this
slide is no matter what you want to do, advertising
serves as a solid base of revenue that is
basically quite reliable. Our ad network is
very built out and there's a lot of demand
for advertising on mobile devices. So if you
can build that audience, that revenue will
always be there and then you can build even
more business on top of that with paid downloads
and within app purchases. Advertising is just
a good baseline. One thing I would recommend
however is, and I recommend this all the time,
actually is if you can have a free version
of your app, you really should. We see conversion
rates on free apps. They're over 10 times
higher than paid apps. It's just something
that if you're in an app store and there's
200,000 apps and one is free and one is paid,
which one are you going to pick? However,
if you've been using a free one for a while,
you really value it, you really like it then
you're going to be more willing to pay for
a paid app. So even if you have a paid app,
if you can give away a free version to get
people into it, I highly recommend that. So,
on the advertising piece of those business
models, the way that AdMob works is really
very easy. We have a series of SDKs available
on our website. And I'll give you guys the
links to those later. You basically download
some libraries and install them in your app.
It takes most app developers about two hours
to say, "This is where I want my apps and
install all--this is where I want my ads and
install all of the code." And we start to
show ads in your app. Generally, every time
a user clicks on one of those ads, you get
paid. So--and then there's--that's the CPC
model. That's when advertisers are paying
for clicks. There's also a CPM model which
is when advertisers are paying for impressions.
So basically, every time an ad shows whether
the user clicks on it or not, you also get
paid. You can place these banners anywhere
in your app. You can have them on menu pages,
you can have them anywhere within the actual
content of the app, you can have them on instruction
pages. What you should think about if you're
going to build an app that is going to be
ad supported is building the app in such a
way that it optimizes the user experience
because you don't want to alienate users by
having too many ads or ads in annoying places
like in the middle of the screen or next to
buttons that they're trying to use for functionality
so they accidentally click on the ad. You
don't want to have any of that stuff because
then you'll end up losing users. So you want
to optimize for both user experience as well
as revenue potential. So things like having
it on the menu screen, that's a good place
to have an ad because that's when a user is
paying a lot of attention and it's not distracted
by any content that your app might have. Some
examples of ad units that we serve, things
that--ad types that you might receive as an
AdMob publisher, for example, Click to Call.
So an advertiser might want the user to call
in, in order to sell them something. This
would be some--this ad unit, when you click
on it, it actually initiates a call on the
phone. Obviously, clicking to mobile landing
pages is a very common functionality for mobile
advertisements. This is another thing you
might see. And then we also have a new series
of advertisements called Interstitials. These
are extremely high-paying advertisements which--what
they do is when someone turns on your app,
a full screen ad will actually come up and
fill the screen, and it's animated, it's an
interactive experience. You can't really see
it in this slide, but in the slide--in this
advertisement on the right, you can click
on the clouds, move them around, the rainbow
comes out. If you touch the cloud again, a
little skunk comes out. It's fun and entertaining
and most importantly, it doesn't take anyone
out of your app. You can see there's a little
X mark at the top left there. At any moment
if the user gets annoyed, they can click on
the X and they're right back in your app,
but you still get paid for that impression.
So this is one of the things--this is one
of the examples of the innovative ad units
that we have. They were always coming out
with new ones to try to make sure that our
publishers are getting paid as much as possible.
So everyone always wants to know how much
they can make. It really, really, really depends.
Every app is completely different. And so
what I always try to do is give the people
an idea of how to think about it so they can
figure it out for themselves. So what you
need to think about is, "What is the value
of one of my users and how many users do I
have?" And so I'm going to walk through an
example of how you might evaluate that for
your own app. The first thing you need to
know is how to define eCPM. eCPM is a measure
of how much money you're actually making from
serving ads. And it measures how much money
you make when you serve 1,000 ads. So this
is a simplified calculation just using, you
know, easy numbers to make it easy to understand
how this works. In reality, these obviously
vary very widely, but let's say you serve
1,000 ads to your users. If the ads have a
click through rate of 1.5%, meaning 1.5% of
the time when an ad shows, someone clicks
on it, then you've gotten 15 clicks. If the
advertisers who are buying those clicks are
offering to pay 10 cents per click, that's
what CPC stands for, cost per click, well
then 15 times 10 is $1.50. In another words
if you serve a thousands ads, in this example,
you will have made $1.50. So now you understand
what eCPM is. This will make a little more
sense. This is a calculation of a value--of
the value of one free customer; meaning a
customer who downloaded your free app. On
the left side, let's say you have your average
user uses your app 20 times. And let's say
that the way you have your app set-up on average
in one use session, a user sees five ads.
Well, that means that each user on average
that you get is going to see approximately
100 ads. If your eCPM is 100--I'm sorry--$1.50,
well then overall, your average value per
user is 15 cents and that's just from showing
ads. The average value per user is 15 cents.
On the right side, this is saying, "How much
can you make if you are also selling a paid
version to your free users?" So let's assume
that people are using your free app and you
have ads running in your own app saying, "Hey,
upgrade to the paid version to get all of
this great extra feature and functionality."
Let's say 5% of your users upgrade to that
paid app. Let's say the price of the paid
app is $2.99 then that's another 15 cents
average value per user. In other words, your
average total value per user is going to be
15 plus 15 equals 30 cents. So now if you
know the value of a user, then it's all just
about how many users you can get. So, obviously,
the goal is get as many users as possible
and you'll make more money, and try to increase
the value of your users. So this has to do
with showing more ads obviously as well as
coming up with compelling offerings such as,
you know, good in app purchases, a good paid
app to upgrade to and so on and so forth.
To give you an idea, one thing you might want
to think about if you're thinking about types
of apps to develop is how many page views
does your app drive? We see social apps, for
example, drive tons of page views. So messaging
apps, Twitter apps and so on and so forth.
People are using these apps all day long to
send messages, receive messages, and it's
just page views, page views, page views, same
thing with games. People play games for a
very long time. So there's many, many, many
opportunities to show them--to show them ads.
So those are apps that tend to have a very
high value per user. Some apps have--just
by definition, they have less opportunity
to show advertisement. So if you have an app
that is the kind of app that you use to get
a quick piece of information, you're probably
only going to have one ad to show that person
and so you might have a lower value per user.
Then again, if you can get a lot of users,
you can compensate for that. So it's just
a framework for thinking about the type of
app that you have and how you're going to
grow this value of that app. But of course,
one goal should always be, "Get as many users
as possible," and that's also something that
we try to help with. So the complication with
getting a lot of users is that app stores
are really, really crowded. You know, there's
hundreds of thousands of apps in these stores.
So how you're going to get noticed? We've
done research showing that something like
98% of people, the way that they find the
apps that they download is they go into the
app store on their phone and they just kind
of browse. And of course, when you go into
the app store and you browse, what are you
browsing? You're browsing most likely the
top 50 free apps. Maybe you look into a specific
category, but even there, you're also looking
at the top 20 apps in that category. And so
you're going to see maybe, you know, 50 to
100 apps. And they're only going to be the
top ones. And you're not going to find any
of the other 200,000 apps unless you are explicitly
searching for those which doesn't happen nearly
as much as just as casual browsing. So basically,
if you want to get a lot of users, it needs
to be your goal to get up into that place
where you're going to be much more discoverable,
where it's much easier to find you. And so
that's something that we help do through mobile
advertising as well. Basically, what we allow
publishers to do through the same set of tools
that we allow them to monetize their sites
through or their apps through is place advertisements
for their apps on our network of other apps.
So, in this example, Battle Bears is a game
that was developed by one of the developers
we work with. They put--they created an ad--what
you see on the top left there. It has a little
picture of a bear and it says, "Play Battle
Bears. Free download," is a very easy ad to
create. We actually scraped the--we actually
scraped the image from their app tile and
they just provide 35 characters of text, so
extremely easy. We show these ads across our
network. When someone clicks on an ad, it
takes them directly to the app store page
to download the app. This is an example on
iPhone, but it's the exact same thing on Android.
And then someone can choose to install the
app or not. We've shown over time that this
is an extremely effective model and we've
used it with thousands and thousands of apps.
This is just a small sampling of the apps
that we've done this with. And here's a typical--here's
a typical result that you can see from this
kind of campaign. We did an app promotion
campaign for a local app called Radio Skol
which was produced by an app production house
called Aorta. And basically, what we tried
to do is run as many ads as possible within
three or four days. And what that does is
it creates a lot of downloads per day, which
means that then the app store algorithms start
to increase your rank because you look like
a hot app when you're getting that many downloads.
If you start increasing your rank and you
start getting up into the top 100, the top
50, all those people when they're browsing
their phones, they start finding you a lot
more. And so they may start downloading you
more. So just by getting up there to begin
with, you're going to get up even higher just
from that organic boost effect and you can
see that that's what happened here. When--before
the campaign, they were getting, you know,
a very small number of downloads per day.
On the right axis there, you can see, they
are probably getting maybe 30 downloads per
day. And then as we increase their rank, which
is on the left side there and we got them
as high as number 10 in the app store, they
were getting up to 1,200 app--1,200 downloads
a day. So if you want to build users, this
is a great way to do so. And by the way, as
the app stores grow, you know, being number
10 is definitely not 1,200 downloads per day
anymore. It's a much larger number because
there are that many more users, that many
more apps in the app store. So to be in number
10 takes a lot more downloads per user. In
other words, the opportunity to acquire users
is huge. Finally, one last thing you can do
to drive downloads of your products is to
cross-promote them. So if you have more than
one app, our tools allow you to use a free
functionality called House ads. So if I am
the publisher of Strike Knight and Ninja Jump
and I'm coming out with a new app called Buganoids,
I can actually, for free, put advertisements
for Buganoids within my existing apps. And
that's a way to cross-promote my new apps
to my existing users. It's completely free
to the publisher and it allows you to build
on the strength of your audience creations.
So the more audience you create, the--it's
a virtuous cycle. And this is--this is a free
functionality in our tool. So when you combine
all of these strategies, you can build a really
strong business. This is one example of a
publisher we worked with in the U.S. called
Backflip Studios, who is on our advertising,
earning $100,000 a month. And they're doing
this plus CNET purchases, plus upgrade to
paid versions. And there's no reason why developers
down here can't make the same kind of income.
You know, earlier, I showed the number of
unique users and the number of page views
in Brazil. There's no reason why you have
to have your app promoted only in Brazil.
You can develop an app that can be promoted
in the app stores in the U.S. and in Europe
as well. So, this sort of thing is completely
feasible and, in fact, this is just one of
the--actually, many, many developer companies
who are making this kind of money right now
with iPhone and Android apps. So I encourage
everyone to just give our tools a shot on
admob.com. We have really good reporting and
analytics so that you can track your performance
in real time. You can log in whenever you
want and see how much money you're making
on a given day. You can break it down by geography.
You can design a custom dashboard. It's a
very good set of tools for understanding how
your business is running. And this is how
you would do that. Just check out admob.com
where you can create an account. Our SDKs
are there. You can just download them for
free. And these links down here, we will take
you to help center in Wikis where you could
get help on installing them. So, that's it.
I tried to make it quick. I hope it was interesting.